à notre époque où durant surtout ces
dernières années les relations humaines
se sont singulièrement réduites par
suite de la prolifération des machines
des ordinateurs des fiches et du thym
devenu aussi sacrée que l'argent lui
même sacraliser les lettres sont devenus
plus précieuse que jamais
j'ai toujours éprouvé beaucoup
d'admiration pour ces travailleurs
anonymes qui vivent à contretemps et
achemine de courrier pendant que nous
nous reposons et aussi pour les facteurs
c'est moderne mercure maintenant que la
plupart des femmes travaillent à
l'extérieur ils n'ont plus affaire qu'à
des boîtes le verre de vin coffre teinte
claudine représentants des ptt dans
fannie de marcel pagnol c'était
tellement sympathique dans les régions
d'habitat dispersé n'ont ils pas
constitué durant un instant le seul lien
d isoler avec le reste du monde avant le
développement de la radio de la
télévision
cette lettre dont le courrier dojo du
madame envoyé par madame cardas
téléspectatrices d'arras a retenu votre
attention
y at-il vraiment plus en france de ton
de claudine pour offrir un verre de vin
aux facteurs et de facteurs pour le
boire en ville non mais à la campagne
un matin à l'arrivée du train postal
nous sommes retrouvés à carcassonne
capitale du département de l'aude pour
faire connaissance d'un facteur de la
région jean ferré notre vide
je suis facteur tu as le mans depuis à
peu près 15 ans et je suis dans l'eau
d'heure avec approximativement depuis
dix ans avait chuté à paris et j'ai
quitté cette région après mutation mais
que je n'ai pas du tout regretté
d'ailleurs
actuellement je me trouve très très bien
ici à 41,25 facteurs
[Musique]
couiza
[Applaudissements]
quand on met une lettre à la boîte on ne
pense jamais à tous les modes de
transport qu'elle va emprunter à toutes
les correspondances qu'elle ne devra pas
rater pour atteindre son but un
itinéraire étonnant de précision et de
rapidité mais c'est une autre histoire
avant d'arriver entre les mains du
facteur qui la distribuera
oh
m
oui
le matin nous arrivons nous avons du
courrier qui arrive et qui viennent de
personnes que nous trium
alors ensuite nous les classons par
tourner au classement par tourner et le
parton de approximative est un lutteur
demi 20h45 en distribution ou de rentrer
en contact avec les jeunes
pour divers problèmes c'est à dire soit
financier placement d'argent
caisse d'épargné bons du trésor c'est de
payer on fait un peu de tout quoi disons
qu'on est un facteur un peu qui arrive à
rendre service à tous ses clients
le facteur aujourd'hui il se voit de
loin sa voiture jaune au sigle bleu est
devenu le signe de ralliement de tous
ceux qui vivent isolés et l'aude est une
des régions de france où il ya le moins
d'habitants au kilomètre carré
attendrissante obstiné comme un petit
cheval courageux la voiture du facteur
passe partout réussissant à être à
l'heure dans n'importe quelle
circonstance
avec elle le facteur à porte et emporte
le courrier assurant à la fois ramassage
et distribution
il fait tellement partie de la vie
quotidienne le facteur qu'on ne le voit
même plus on le devine
oui voilà
bonjour je viens au bois merci ça va
voir
ça mais ce n'était pas fameux mettez un
peu de mémoire est
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
passé
qu'est ce que vous attendez du facteur
qui vous apporte des nouvelles quelles
nouvelles mais savent pas ils vous
répondent souvent eh oui
sur balles vous écrivez beaucoup à vos
enfants au stade chaoui
le net vous pouvez vous montrer ce que
vous avez joué que je sais pas où nous
rit on voulait les voir oui
[Musique]
il est beau ce coffret taille bon
voilà même temps la belgique au chalet
de belgique de belgique comment ça se
fait que vous connaissez des belges et
les v10 refuge chez nous qu'en fin de la
guerre et après la guerre qu'est ce qui
s'est passé alors bien des jeunes dès
qu'il ya vraiment là plus de nouvelles
jusqu'à maintenant
de 18 du tout le mois de juin 2 mai à 74
que j'ai reçu des nouvelles de shopping
et qu'est ce qu'elle vous disais ça fait
lesquels il est venu nous voir et on
l'attend toujours vous gardez d'autres
lettres comme ça précieux et on rit
jamais si jamais c'est peut-être l'un
avoue pour sa
part
de tout cas ce qu'à ça monsieur
président de l'ird et en ciel je le
regarde je me
relire une lettre n'est ce pas tenter de
retrouver le plaisir ressenti un instant
où il ouvre pour la première fois
oui mais
pas
tous il est 9h du mat et comme je n'ai
rien fait d un profit tout on perd
quelques lignes
s'était bien passé à part que je suis
allé aux coiffeurs et quand je me suis
senti quelque chose
nous ne voulons nous aurait une telle
mission pour ce dimanche est donc
vendredi soir je serai des bourses et de
ce fait je voudrais être leur sera faite
d'arc bien soit j'ai été portée des
papiers pour ma libération une
discipline je crois que maintenant il
n'y a plus qu'à attendre pour savoir le
résultat j'espère le chef bd que si tu
vas toujours dingue et les filles de
rennes
tu dois avoir autant de chances que ça
me dis donc à l'image
est ce que vous aimez votre voiture est
ce que vous sentez bien avec elle oui ça
c'est mon outil de travail d'ailleurs
parce que si jamais je me laisse en
panne vous savez je suis là haut dans la
montagne heureux ici combien de me
dépanner alors j'essaie de le faire le
maximum avec
elle est vivante
[Musique]
m
quand même là est toujours certain flou
dieu sait pas alors j'ai peut-être
croyez nous avons besoin de temps
pendant les poules aux oeufs d'or
j'aimerais ça s'est passé parce qu'il
pleut ou s'il vient vers la boîte eh
bien
oui merci allez voir le 12 les patins
bon je m'en faisais je les ai
vous avez connu beaucoup de facteurs je
suis sûr oui on en a connu la paix ils
ont été tous gentils monsieur ferry où
j'étais jeune tous ces jeunes qui mène
vers le japon bien non il n'est pas tel
vous l'accueillez toujours chez vous
quand il vient il s'arrête ah oui plus
que toi oui toi je vous vois tous les
jours les lenteurs
est ce que les femmes n'attendent plus
que les hommes aussi le vin parce que
les gens me font tourner dans les
charmes et les femmes dans la maison
d'habitude où le merlan les chiens comme
ça des fois je puis au facteur quand on
appelle le voyez il a lui passé on s'y
habitue doit habituellement louis pas
chez relay si on a pas mal aussi un peu
plus qu'il est
ce que d'habitude parce que toujours à
peu près en même temps
si on vous l'enlevez qu'est ce que ça
vous ferait on pas on ne savait pas
comptable
pendant ma mère je
l'attendais longtemps enfin une nouvelle
fois faire passer mais il ne portait pas
de nouveaux éléments les nouvelles de
qui est nouvellement fait
combien de temps vous avez attendu
nouvel quinze jours
et ce qui se passait alors le facteur
venait oui en fait elle venait il nous
colle terriens ont été malheureux
lui aussi il loge dit oui
et comment ça s'est terminé
eelv et le jaune qui nous apportait la
laiterie il était content aussi
vous m'avez dit quelque chose tout à
l'heure
à propos de cette arrivée du secteur
il mange à une jambe et le ton était sur
la route là ils étaient gaulois
est il appelé de nouveau lundi pour
trouver les chevaux là on a été
comptable il a attendu que vous ayez
vers la lettre dans les
montagnes où
ils étaient contents d'en importer
ouvert la bouche il nous tardait vous
savez
souvent dit non japonaise rating à
petits pas sur la boîte là pour prouver
vous donnez leur le manteau est pauvre
il a vécu bien voyez d'être utile et
rêveur
olé quand il pleuvait ou qui faisait foi
comme ça il faut effacer boutonnet il
nous appelait mon père dans la tête
qu'il faut chercher matin parce qu'à ce
moment-là il invitait à bruxelles il
allait chercher la correspondance hier
que remonter
puis des fois on lui recommande lui
demande de nous faire une commission à
bruxelles montréal ou comme travailler
des fois ils nous avaient rapporté des
rumeurs de la pharmacie de couiza
pour notre vieil aubin ou
si on a besoin de leur aide et louis
portes
pour une visite et j'utilise le capteur
et puis quand le cocktail pas nouvelle
toutes les campagnes autour de mon nom
tandis qu'à ce moment là et on ne sait
rien sur le facteur on est désespérés
ici
le facteur rural a quand même un métier
un peu différent de celui du facteur
davis est pas tout à fait pareil tu vois
ce nous rentrons davantage en contact
avec le client et je crois que c'est ce
qu'a fait la valeur c'est vraiment
valable vous n'êtes pas simplement un
monsieur qui dépense des lettres ou des
journaux non pas du tout
non parce que moi je suis le client de
chez lui on arrive à discuter et puis je
trouve aussi très bien demander nouvelle
si ces biens concernés disons qu'on est
de la famille quoi
[Musique]
puisque vous avez tendance à quelque
chose de plus pour les gens qui en ont
plus besoin je pense pour les personnes
âgées oui oui parce que j'estime que
celui qui n'a rien pour se déplacer qui
est assez âgée mais je crois que c'est à
cela qu'il faut rendre le service c'est
le vélo m'a fait beaucoup de cas où ils
sont embêtés pour ne pas pouvoir se
déplacer si j'ai une condition à leur
faire soit un produit pharmaceutique ab
que c'est de leur prendre et je leur
porte en messieurs d'ailleurs
et ça m'est arrivé de des fois de
tourner et déjà malade oui je suis
malade je sais pas quoi faire je ne peux
pas me remettre en jeu leur dire laissez
faire un effort depuis quand faut il
arrive à les convaincre ça c'est
difficile 10 ans d'un règne arrive quand
même
[Musique]
à
l'arrivée du facteur le travail s'arrête
pendant quelques instants
c'est la halte attendu dans le dur
labeur quotidien l'occasion de parler un
peu de se détendre ok
bonjour
ba
est aux ordres
étaient hier
aujourd'hui vous avez pas tardé vous
allez voir que l'eau françois nogué
les enfants vérité ah bon mais là
bonjour ça va
c'est vous qui habitez vaste enclos
l'algérie c'est bien oui vous allez
dans mon vol était annulé
ici pas ici
et oui on se prépare à
aller voir et revoir ya une leur donnant
tous tellement ici
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
la distribution du courrier c'est sur un
certain nombre de kilomètres vous fait
combien de kilomètres par jour
normalement la tournée inconfortable et
sam
12h21 jury ne pas le faire parce qu'il
ya quand même des firmes éloignés qu'ils
sont un groupe de fabriquer comme été
bonne dans l'est d'ailleurs
espérant qu'un jour le seront c'était
des gens que vous aimez pourquoi ou pour
la nature le beau qu est ce qu est la
particule cette marche est beau
[Musique]
ce sont des pays très bon
oui moi sur un tournage et le château de
serres hle
dong van darc et puis le château de
busan et chatons qui en était le tapis
qui sonne d'ailleurs très très bien
actuellement c'est joli c'est beau à
voir l'exploit journalier d'un secteur
rural c'est d'arriver à consacrer à
chacun suffisamment de temps pour qu'il
soit satisfait tout en respectant son
d'horaires pour tous les autres qui
l'attendent il a encore beaucoup qui
s'abonnent aux journaux beaucoup puisque
toutes les campagnes de façon dont les
gens là allez tous tout ce soit le
quotidien la dépêche le midi libre le
d-pad dame tout le monde à ce jour là
mais
je sais bien que certaines ne pas le
jouer c'est plutôt flatteur ils ont le
journal ça me fait plaisir quoi d'avoir
des nouvelles même fait une gouaille
sommes très très contents qu'elle est
même certain qu'ils entassent les
journaux justement ils s'entassent les
journaux ça déchire les bandes
[Musique]
les enfants sont très mignons tous
sympathiques je reconnais que à la
campagne je crois qu'ils ont ils ont la
possibilité d'avoir une autre du patient
je trouve je vous rends compte et bien
vous touchez là même dix banques
facturent je trouve ça très sympathique
a alors commis le mal fois le facteur ne
connaissent pas ne vote jamais
le monde paysan évolue lentement et
reste fidèle aux principes réfléchir
avant d'agir
de l'évolution des chèques que le mans
il ya très peu très peu demande a même
fait qu'on est arrivé à récupérer tous
ces chèques dix
hommes de débâcle des crédits n'est pour
qu'elle compte qu'on est arrivé quand
même la personne ait récupéré ce qui
fait que ça nous fait quand même un
trafic assez normal partout
[Musique]
je crois que j'ai eu un client qui à peu
près pour le convaincre sur ce tout
simplement sur un livret de que ce
départ il m'a fallu à peu près un an
pour y arriver mais fait quand même
[Musique]
merriman et celle ci encore plus beau
voulez-vous et on détourne pas
aujourd'hui
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mais mon petit sac tu
savais comme à la parade du lez on peut
tout résoudre et là aussi nature
voilà
allez
[Musique]
voir
moi j'aimais bien le vin de service et
c'est normal d'ailleurs
je sais pas je trouve naturel
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
connu
j'avais nouvelle je dis oui cathay si
vous avez eu un bon jour même s'il a
écrit c'est lui qui est christiane
astucieux c'est bien il a perdu ce stylo
il ne peut plus réécrire
eu lieu mercredi prochain
pour ce sont des humains qui sont en
très mauvais état et communes ont
beaucoup de difficultés pour les
entretenir et j n'y a presque plus
personne qui veut rester à part quelques
personnes âgées encore qui sont par là
mais des jeunes on n'en voit plus et le
monde est sympa
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
pour tout le monde des affaires voilà
c'est tout c'est tout c'est tout mais
c'est pas beaucoup non un peu plus loin
d'y voir enfin motivation
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bien sûr il ya des boîtes mails sont
utilisés qu'en cas d'absence vers le
facteur est aussi important que la
lettre qu'il apporte une joie une peine
un souci quand on est loin de tout il
est bon de les partager avec quelqu'un
[Musique]